this morning on the dish
the home cook who became a restaurant
superstar and the cookbook he just
published has quickly become one of our
favorites
ned baldwin was originally a sculptor
and didn't get into a professional
kitchen until he was 35.
he opened houseman in new york city in
2015 and this year with peter kaminski
released the book how to dress an egg a
beautiful
inventive approach to a classic genre
with everyone
not just the elite in mind
[Music]
whether he's in the kitchen or on the
water
ned baldwin has shaped a captivating
career
after starting as a sculptor baldwin
turned his passion for home cooking
professional some people think the
transition from sculpting to having a
restaurant or cooking is
is is crazy but i mean you're you're
sculpting when you're making
the food right you're you're making
stuff with your hands
which is for me sort of the baseline
that's what i do i make stuff with my
hands
baldwin opened houseman in new york city
in 2015
and soon found himself serving a legend
in the food writing business
peter kaminsky who was co-written books
with many famous chefs
and food fans including daniel ballou
francis mullman and john madden
but his other passion was what they
connected on fishing
you're eating at his place and he comes
up to you
and you think you're about to have a
food conversation right but no ned had
read a book that i wrote called the moon
pulled up an acre of bass
turned out he's a maniac fisherman as
well so we enjoyed one another on that
level
and i really liked the food so i kept
coming back there
one day kaminsky called baldwin with an
idea to collaborate on a cookbook i
didn't know what kind of cookbook i
could write and
i said no i don't want to do a cookbook
i can't right now
i'm totally crushed by the restaurant so
he um he said
these fateful words he said it takes a
long time to write a cookbook
five years later the two have given us
this
how to dress an egg he's this guy who
took his love of home cooking
learned some techniques in a restaurant
and tried to get his cooks in his
kitchen
to really make perfectly simple home
food and serve it to customers yeah they
should have like a teeny bit of crunch
they'll
feel a little bit fresh in order to do
that you have to come up with recipes
that are idiot-proof it's a very you
know
accomplished level of home cooking
there's there's 100 million cookbooks
it's tough to break through with one i
think this this one does
why do you think that is and don't be
modest
[Laughter]
um well it's very personal i suppose
that's one thing
i think maybe partly it's because of the
relationship that peter and i had
what is it you try to bring out of chefs
on the page that you think they
may not be able to do by themselves
when you write a book with a chef i
always look for
what turns them on in cooking
baldwin's calling card has always been
to eschew the high falutin extras
and focus on what matters like in my
house and in
almost all of my friends houses there
are two bookshelves
for cookbooks there's the bookshelf in
the living room with the big ones the
great
photographs and then there's a shelf in
the kitchen with dirty books
and the covers are a little messed up
and they're the ones you go to
you know every night like okay i'm gonna
cook chicken a night oh ned's got five
chicken recipes in this one maybe we'll
use one of those
from the beginning it was really
important to me to try to get onto that
shelf
the dirty shelf the dirty shelf when
he's not riding
or running the restaurant these days you
can probably find baldwin off the north
fork of long island
his boat is named after his wife and his
daughter
it's been a nice bond with with the kids
with your son
yeah my daughter who's 13
used to go out with me some her name's
hazel i said hazel do you like fishing
and she goes
i like being with you daddy so i was
like okay
i'm not gonna make you go fishing
anymore we can just hang out but my son
is into it and he's good he's talented
baldwin's son irv helped us catch this
black sea bass
it's a great fish for grilling it's one
of the tastiest fish in the sea and
there are
lots and lots of them which ned stuff
generously was salt
lemon and herbs and pepper too no pepper
don't believe in pepper i'm pretty uh
pretty open to herbs of all kinds right
now we've got marjoram
tarragon and cilantro we're going to
stuff all those in there
i like to take the butt end of it and
put it up towards the head that's the
stiffer end of the herb
so we'll get that in there the bass
takes about seven minutes on the grill
oh it smells good and was served
alongside
hanger steak beet cappanada
carrots with ricotta and pumpkin seeds
japanese eggplant with tahini sauce a
leafy salad
this baldwin classic an inspiration for
the title of his book
dressed eggs with sliced almonds and
horseradish
and a spicy chocolate ganache with bread
and peaches
and variety of ways to use that we do a
venetian hot chocolate which is
hot chocolate like you've never had
before it's rich and creamy
and thick my kids are crazy for it i
think we even titled it in the book
hazel's hot chocolate
and this is the fish we just cooked yeah
mixed peppers that are grilled
and then the skins pulled off and sliced
and then also grilled cherries
all of it polished off with a woodford
reserve manhattan
last but not least yeah cheers cheers
thanks for coming out of course it's
tremendous
yum fabulous one a few more
anybody want one yeah
we'd like one like when i'm getting the
look i'm getting the look
she's get there it is sorry it's now in
person i i promise i'll make
fish and like a beautiful feast for you
as soon as i possibly can
well you brought pumpkins i brought
pumpkins this book i mean it's it
the reason why it's so cool first it's
beautiful it's just really well put
together but also just the concept you
know it took them five years to come up
with this
just the idea that you can make this one
ingredient make one thing really good
and from all that everything else it
really did look delicious
it was